Have you ever had your knitting fall off
the machine, get your carriage stuck,
or find that a stitch
pattern is just not working?
Even the most experienced machine knitter
has one of THOSE days, now and then.
In this video,
we'll cover some of the common things
that can happen,
and we'll talk about how to avoid them.
A lot of things can go
wrong when casting on.
I can't cover all
the different cast-on methods.
Each has their own little quirk, but there
are some general things to watch out for.
If your carriage jams after you cast on,
it might be that the carriage isn't
seated correctly on the needle bed.
Remove it and the yarn,
replace the carriage,
and run it across the needle bed
with all the needles out of work.
It should move smoothly and easily.
Maybe your cast on is too tight.
Remove the yarn from the needles and cast
on more loosely with the method of your
choice, or maybe try
a different cast on method.
Check to make sure that you're using
the yarn that's the correct size
for the needles of your machine.
When you're using the right yarn,
your carriage will move smoothly
and easily and won't jam.
Maybe the yarn tension is too tight.
Make sure that it's not caught up
in the yarn guides and check maybe
the tensioner for tangles and knots.
It needs to be loose enough to feed
through the carriage
so it can move easily.
If you've pulled all the needles out maybe
to do an E-wrap cast on and they don't
knit when you push the carriage across,
maybe you have the machine set to hold.
Check your hold setting on your carriage,
disable the hold, and try again.
Sometimes after casting on all
the stitches drop or they make
large loops in a big yarn mess.
Check to make sure that the yarn is
engaged in the yarn feeder
of the carriage correctly.
Also, check that it's in the right feeder.
Some machines have two yarn feeders.
Another thing that can happen is that your
sinker plate is not seated
properly in the carriage.
Remove the carriage,
reseat that sinker plate, and try again.
If, after casting on some stitches drop
at the beginning of the row,
your yarn is probably too loose.
Try again and adjust the tensioner
and try taking up the slack of the yarn
at the beginning of the row.
If stitches drop in the middle of the row,
probably the sinker plate
is not seated properly.
Loosen the screws holding the sinker
plate, push them back in,
reseed it, take the whole carriage off.
Make sure that the sinker plate is
attached to the carriage correctly.
Another issue could be that yarn
is tangled in the sinker brushes.
Remove your carriage, look underneath,
make sure there isn't any yarn or lint
stuck in those brushes.
Now, if the stitches drop in the middle
of the row, the cast-on might
be too loose or just uneven.
Confirm that the stitches of your
original cast-on are even.
If you find that stitches are tucking or
they just don't knit off the needles
properly,
your cast on is probably too tight
or the stitch tension is way too low.
Those stitches are way too tight.
You can knit individual stitches manually
to fix this or take everything
off the machine and try it again.
Sometimes the stitches just won't knit.
Maybe your cast on is too loose or your
controls are not set to plain knitting.
It sounds silly, but take a look and make
sure that the settings on your
carriage are set for plain knitting.
No matter what's happening,
if you're struggling with your
cast on, check these things.
Are you using the right
yarn for your machine?
Are the settings on your carriage correct?
Is the carriage seated
on the needle bed properly?
Are the sinker plate in the
carriage joined correctly?
Okay.
Check your yarn.
Is it feeding smoothly without any knot,
or tangles, or hangups anywhere?
Is your yarn in the right
feeder of the carriage?
Is your cast on too tight, too loose?
Try this.
Try casting on with another method.
You might have more success.
Sometimes all it takes is getting up,
taking a deep breath, walk away, and come
back to it, and your problem is solved.
Happy knitting.